yes that's the spirit oh hell yeah now
there's been a lot of games based on
battle tech tell us about this
incarnation
by all means battle Tech is a modern
turn-based tactical game set within the
MechWarrior universe and there's me
three modes of play a single-player
skirmish a multiplayer skirmish and then
our open-ended mercenary campaign well I
want to hop straight into some of that
single-player content by taking a
journey to the Argo I understand that
you know there's all sorts of combat
goodies that we're going to see in a
moment but the Argo is in between
missions walk us through what we're
saying
so the Argo is broken down a Hulk of a
space state of spaceship from a bygone
era and it is your mercenary command
center you could take it all over the
Oliver space going from star system to
star system and taking mercenary jobs
from all sorts of different people from
petty dictators all the way up to the
great lords and ladies of the noble
houses and from there you can also
command your entire mercenary crew
there's samiri she's your navigator and
you command her and all of your mech
warriors as you take your jobs and
upgrade your ship I'm curious a little
bit about the storyline in the
single-player sure so you're gonna see
it a few moments Lady Kamiya are on oh
she's a deposed ruler her her throne was
taken by her uncle and you are going to
jump in and help her regain her throne
course it's been plunged the whole space
has been plunged into a bloody civil war
these and these are course are the tools
of negotiation and diplomacy called
battle mechs and he ran in the mech bay
which is one of the one of the key
components of the Argo you're able to
customize the mechs adding different
weapons changing out weapons and armor
heatsinks all that kind of stuff
yang here is your master of ceremonies
he's one of the key crew members because
fixing these mechs after you come back
from combat you're a merc you're
supposed to make money taking damage
you know sets you behind and so that
that's a really delicate balancing act I
can imagine that trying to get all the
parts that you need for your ship can be
a little difficult absolutely that's why
things like especially in this time in
era where parts are scarce battlefield
Salvage is an important part of the game
and and that also gets into you know
like when you take out a take on an army
try to leave the parts you want yeah you
want to hit them just hard enough to
take them down
there's lady chimera no there and she's
going to be the person you work for
during the campaign but of course when
the campaign ends the single-player
story ends you can still play the
open-ended campaign traveling around
doing whatever you want and there are
the Bell now yes now we're going to get
a chance to look at the combat itself
they're coming down from the Argo you're
descending into battle walk me through
it we're seeing by all means so battle
took full 3d environment and like a
modern tactical game the environment
counts like line-of-sight sensors cover
even though you're you know friggin 30
foot tall covered in armor hiding in a
forest still helps it soaks off damage
and so all those are kind of core
components of any modern games
especially facing which is very
important this game facing really
matters in battle tech you know battle
max aren't giant bags and hit points
instead they have 11 different armored
locations there's internal structure
they have the internal components these
critical slots filled with all sorts of
important pieces so what you're trying
to do is strip off the armor from one
location and then keep your facing to
try and penetrate it get to the juicy
bit yeah I mean I see this diagram at
the top it's reminiscent of the original
table watch game which I actually played
as a kid and I mean like as a kid huh
thanks pal I mean I understand that you
know is it same sort of idea where
damaging the arm disables that weapon
but I'm anyway going and you keep going
on you blow that arm off and they lose
those weapons and the back is really
juicy and tasty too you get around the
back of a battle mech and penetrate I
said that line right well allow it well
alone are you guys well you just saw
there is melee um one of the one of
things were really excited about I mean
mechs were not only weapon systems
they're giant you know armored suits and
summing up in and being able to slug and
kick and and just you know even put a
foot through a cockpit or death from
above jump jump up and slam down on max
all that stuff is supported in this game
if you really want to manage your heel -
you're walking here these miksa the
pilots are sitting on a
a nuclear reactor basically and so you
really want to watch your heat how much
like the human weapons do because if you
shut down in combat you are quite
vulnerable it's been really fascinating
to watch a lot of the streams because I
know you guys just went into beta where
can the people here go to sign up to
play why shun they can go to battle tech
game.com that's battle tech game.com
come find us on battle tech game comm
and if you're interested any news Mac
this is the guy that that's right
now I'd like to state again battle
technique thank you guys so much for
coming out Jordan Mitch it's been a
pleasure thank you
Cheers now our very next game you may
recognize from PC games past to talk
about it we got Sonya in the mezzanine
Thank You Sean our next game is to come
to us from our friends